[Musik]
und dann gibt es menschen die mehr zählt
acht trifft er die alten ist eine
vorerkrankung ich bin 24 jahre alt und
sitzt sie mit der kette am stand heute
hat kobelt mehr ja meine freiheit um
eine unabhängigkeit genommen
[Applaus]
diese hilflosigkeit dieses nichtstun zu
können und nicht zu wissen ob florian
wieder arbeiten kann dass er wieder
lebensfroh ist wir können natürlich
helfen
aber man kann die allermeisten nicht
heilen
[Musik]
es fühlt sich so an als der mann
durchgehend unter strom
und man weiß aber nicht wo der stecker
ist um ihn auszuschalten und sucht nach
dem aber dieser stecker den gibt es
entweder nicht oder es so gut versteckt
dass man nicht finden kann
[Musik]
ich habe dann irgendwann gemerkt dass
die bio rhythmus sich scheinbar
umgestellt hat und der körper einfach
abends nicht zur ruhe kommen so dass man
denkt man werde müde aber der körper
meint mein herz pocht und mein
herzschlag des weiterhin sehr hoch und
überdurchschnittlich erhöht und der
körper einfach immer akten wie in so
einem aktivitäts zustand gefangen ist
[Musik]
frau professor scheiben dringen können
sie mal beschreiben was sich hinter
diesen chronischen fatigue syndrom
verbirgt es ist ein krankheitsbild bei
dem man also wie der name sagt an
fatigue leidet krankhafte erschöpfung
aber es ist vieles mehr
die patienten haben ein immer auch
kognitive störung das heißt sie können
sich nicht konzentrieren
im englischen gibt es den passenden
begriff gehirn nebel und das ganz
charakteristisch für die erkrankung ist
es dass man sich kaum noch belasten kann
und wenn man sich zu sehr belastet ist
ein paar tage schlechter geht trifft das
vor allem ältere menschen oder kann es
auch junge menschen treffen das ist
überwiegend eine erkrankung von jüngeren
menschen und ist eine erkrankung die
auch doppelt so häufig bei frauen
auftritt und das hat wahrscheinlich
damit zu tun dass es eine erkrankung ist
so das immunsystem nach der infektion
nicht mehr richtig zur ruhe kommt
ich denke es vor allem die verschwommene
sicht und mein mann meine augen schärfe
die sich im zeitverlauf verschlechtert
hat ich denke auch darauf dass ich nicht
mehr so schnell denken kann
vielleicht reicht immer noch auf um sich
ja auto zu fahren aber das risiko möchte
ich einfach selber nicht eingehen zumal
ich weiß dass mein kopf nicht
hundertprozentig funktioniert und ich
erwarten vermutlich nicht mehr so
reaktionszeiten im sommer hab ich halt
jede woche beim telefonieren gemerkt
dass die sprache und auch der dialog
immer schwieriger wurde
er hat die wörter suchen müssen
es wurden keine vollständigen sätze mehr
gesprochen er hat wird beide viel
geweint aus verzweiflung und das war
dann für mich einfach der punkt wo ich
gesagt habe ich muss ihn heimholen ich
habe angst um mein kind dass mein kind
stirbt
ja klar mann mann mann beschützt diese
hoffnung die young lodert dass ich alles
irgendwie von heute auf morgen wieder
auflöst und man wieder an seinen die
volle freiheit wieder zurückbekommt und
die unabhängigkeit genießt die man davor
hatte
[Musik]
beim wedeler jährigen sohnes für java
immer fitter
der hat nie schnell aufgegeben bzw er
war halt hat nie so schnell pausen
wartet welche viel kraft und ja auch mal
gestritten habe
das halt jetzt einfach nicht mehr so
weit wenn sie mal öfter einfach schlecht
geht und dann einfach seine ruhe braucht
um zurück sich zurückzieht
[Musik]
ok
corona schöne geschichte schwere
angelegenheit aber interessantes thema
wenn man studieren sind im alltag
generell einfach nur scheiße steigt von
der stunde ging es dann mit herzrasen
und geht weiter und dass ich keine luft
mehr bekommen habe schon wieder
und dann gibt es menschen die mehr
erzählen acht stellen die alten 8 bis
10uhr vorerkrankung ich bin 24 jahre alt
und sitzt sie mit der karte kann nicht
mehr meinen eigenen und zu machen bin
nicht in der lage anständig zu arbeiten
ich dass uns auch so kann mich nicht
konzentrieren erzählt von dem was ich
tun wollte und da draußen sitzen
wirklich menschen die mir erzählen
wollen es ist ja nicht so stimmt
deswegen bin ich auch in dieser in
dieser facebook-gruppe drin aber einfach
dieses der austausch über über lange
zeit beschwerden und das was andere
leute noch so beschäftigt das hilft
schon extrem
und vor allem hat man so ein
unterstützungs raum einfach kein raum wo
immer das kleingeredet wird haben sie
erkennt dass er dazu wie viele menschen
in deutschland das betrifft
genaue daten haben wir noch nicht
momentan können wir nur grobe
schätzungen machen und wir haben daraus
mal ganz vorsichtig geschätzt dass es
vielleicht ein bis zwei prozent auch der
jüngeren sind die jetzt so chronische
verläufe haben etwas was heißt das das
sind nicht wenig wenn man sich anschaut
wie viele menschen infiziert sind die
haben ja offizielle zahlen in
deutschland schon über zwei millionen
wissen auch wir haben eine dunkelziffer
wir wissen auch die epidemie ist noch
nicht zu ende das könnte also heißen
dass wir vielleicht ende dieses jahres
mit 100.000 menschen zu tun haben wenn
ich jetzt mal so eine zahl schätzen darf
die am chronischen fertig syndrom leiden
leute irgendwie zu glauben dass euch das
nicht treffen kann oder das ist nicht so
schlimm ist und auch ich bin ja jung und
bei mir passiert schon nichts ich habe
das auch gedacht ich dachte ich bin 24
ich habe keinerlei allergien kann
krankheiten kein garnichts kelten
raucher war fällt jetzt nicht so als
risikofaktor was passiert meine
komplette lunge ist so dass ich noch
nicht mal zehn minuten muss die gegend
laufen kann ohne dass man eine halbe
stunde pause zu machen
[Musik]
auf der arbeit merck ist auch extrem
also ich bin einfach nicht mehr nicht
mehr so belastbar ich kann nicht mehr so
viel tragen neben unten unser unser
lagern um sich dann die treppen hoch und
früher bin ich dann den arm voll mit dem
arm und dann noch in den hinten zwei
haken bratwürstchen und dafür muss ich
gerade drei mal gehen weil es ich
schaffe es einfach nicht mit dieser
belastung diese treppen hoch zu kommen
ohne oben nicht hast fast umzukippen
[Musik]
weil einfach der tatsache dass ich halt
studiere und die wohnung sich
finanzieren lassen will irgendwie aber
das schon schon recht wichtig auch recht
schnell wieder zur arbeit zurückzukehren
die kohle ist kann ich mal so unwichtig
in dem moment dann leider
[Musik]
auch mit der uni nehmen fragt sich
natürlich schaffe ich meine klausuren
wenn dann in dem moment mal so einen
blackout einfach einfach ist und ich
vielleicht sogar vergessen wo ich gerade
so zu sagen warum ich danke besitze oder
so was also das sind durchaus dinge die
man eigentlich mehr versucht ein
bisschen zu verdrängen und einfach nicht
drüber nachzudenken
das sind ja also ich hab hab mir dass
mir selber das erst vor einigen tagen
jetzt eingestanden dass ich wirklich
angst haben und ignoranten draußen
behaupten so zwanziger uns heimlich doch
nur ein fall unter das schönste war
ich glaube ja gar nicht dass sie möglich
kommune hatte für mich hat vor allem
geholfen zu verstehen dass wir nicht zu
zweit sind sondern dass tausende
dahinter stehen in deutschland aber auch
weltweit vor allem und zu sehen wie
andere leute die die thematik angehen
und von von deren ansätzen zu lernen
welche medikamente verschrieben wurden
von ärzten weil das oftmals auch von
land zu land unterschiedlich sein kann
die symptome sind relativ vielschichtig
am anfang waren sie relativ fokussiert
würde ich sagen auf diese arten probleme
typische grippe probleme und
mittlerweile oder im zeitverlauf hat
sich sehr so auf den kompletten körper
aus gewaltet es reicht von herz kopf
oder hirn bis hin zu magenproblemen bis
der ganze körper ist faktisch hat
betroffen sie forschen schon wer lange
am chronischen fertigten druck hat das
jetzt durch kurven schub nach vorne
gegeben
ja das hatte sich am muss dazu wissen
hier an der charité gab es schon lange
eine sprechstunde für dieses post
infektiöse chronische fertig syndrom
das ist so dass überhaupt noch gibt hat
mich sehr überrascht dass also eine
erkrankung gibt diese häufig ist so
schwer ist junge leute betrifft und die
man noch kaum kennt wo wir also anders
als bei den meisten anderen erkrankungen
heute den mechanismus noch nicht
verstehen und deswegen auch noch keine
medikamente haben um das gezielt zu
behandeln und um das aber wirklich und
zu können brauchen wir zugelassene
medikamente und dafür brauchen wir
zunächst klinische studien und daran
das momentan noch weil einfach die
pharmazeutische industrie da bislang
sehr konservativ war und gesagt hat so
lange ihr uns nicht genau sagt was der
mechanismus der erkrankung ist es sonst
das zu riskant da haben wir die kamenzer
zu entwickeln
[Musik]
es ist schwierig weil man sich ja was
eine komplette veränderung ist eine von
hundert auf null oder von 90 auf 10
ich selber kann versucht damit
bestmöglich umzugehen und mich an die
neue realität anzupassen
am ende kann ich sie nicht ändern es
gibt definitiv frage da an rind die
zähne über die backe und die diese tage
sind auch häufiger und dann muss man
sich halt einfach irgendwie auf die tage
zurück erinnern oder mit den mit den
eltern sprechen und auf die an
die man man kann das nicht so gut
kontrollierten manchmal
[Musik]